hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar including spatial proteomics in
your research why and how i am marie
stone of labyrinths and i'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by lunafore
to learn more visit luna4.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
charlotte stadler head of the national
spatial proteomics facility in stockholm
sweden charlotte you may now begin your
presentation
hi everyone and thank you for giving me
the opportunity to present here today so
before i start i want to apologize for
my sore throat
i hope that my voice will bear with me
for the whole presentation elsa will
have to make a very short break
so i will talk about including special
proteomics in your research why and how
and
jumping directly to the y i want to show
you this analogy with fruits but i think
it's a very nice illustration of how
spatial analysis brings added value to
omics studies
and this is represented by a city
smoothly here to the left
that is for bulk analysis where we can
identify thousands of proteins or
constituents of a cell
but we cannot tell what proteins come
from which cell or cell type
we then have the single cell methods in
the middle where we can identify the
composition of
individual cells or in a sample like in
single cell rna sequencing or flow
cytometry based methods to get the
composition of different cell types in a
sample
but
if we want to get to know the spatial
analysis and how
let's say different cell types or
proteins interact we do need to get to
the spatial analysis of intact tissue
samples to give us this in-situ
information
and i believe that imaging
has an adhered advantage here as imaging
is all about visualizing
intact protein samples and i want to
show you a few examples of the power of
images and how they have the possibility
to retain both single cell resolution
the spatial information and also the
conceptual contextual information so
here we have one example of a prostate
tissue a prostate gland where we see the
all of the cells outlining the gland and
we have in this case noob 68 which is a
particular protein that target the
nuclear membrane
here is yet another example from the
human protein atlas that we work very
close to
and here we can really see the benefits
how we can capture rare events that
things start resolution so here we have
bob 1b the same protein that localizes
to the centromere up in the right corner
of the cell during mitosis while being
localized to the cytokinetic bridge at
the lower edge of our image
in these two cells that are at the end
of cytokinesis
so
imaging
and looking at proteins is very useful
for addressing a lot of different
questions and i think that's
spatial mapping of the human proteome as
this has been done within the human
protein at this project very nicely
demonstrates this
so just to give you everyone a very
short recap this project is about
mapping the human proteome using
in-house generated antibodies for
imaging of cells and tissues and all of
this data is really available in the
database
and it contains
10 millions of images using more than 25
000 in-house generated antibodies
towards more than 17 000 unique proteins
and i'm saying this because this is
something that i will get back to later
when i talk about comets that i will
also touch upon a lot in this
presentation
but if we don't talk about spatial
proteomics and why this is important i
want to share some of the lessons
learned from the human protein athletes
and how
image-based proteomics provide a lot of
important information so
from
looking at around 17 000 proteins
protein coding genes with
immunohistochemistry across a variety of
tissue types 44 different tissue types
using 24 000 antibodies we've seen that
50 of all genes are housekeeping
and so that the proteins are localized
50 of all the proteins are basically
localized in all tissue types and most
tissue-specific genes and proteins are
expressed in the testings brain and
liver so this is more of like a global
scale
and if we move towards more single cell
methods where we use immunoresistance
instead to map the subcellular
localization of proteins we have also
done so for 12 000 proteins and here we
have been able to define
uh 13 different organelle proteins so
telling like what proteins are expressed
in what in what organelle of the cell
and what is strikingly and very
important to remember is that we've seen
that around 50 percent of all proteins
are multi-localizing and that means that
they are present not only in one
organelle but in different locations of
the cell imply that would have several
different functions depending on where
they are
and we've also seen a malonburg's lab
that around
almost almost 20 percent of all of the
proteins also show some seeing a cell
variability so like cell to cell
variations and this is also a nice paper
out in that if you're interested in
looking at
so there are all the different reasons
for looking at a lot of different
proteins in the cells
and
the only the limitation of all of the
work that has been done in the protein
atlas has taken many many years and one
of the reasons is that we've been
looking at one protein at a time so one
sample is one protein and then some
reference markers
but in many cases we would like to look
at very many proteins but in the very
same sample and this is true in
particularly when we get to tissue
samples
and why is that then
so
as most of us know tissue samples are
very complex and if we look at this
schematic here to the right illustrating
a tumor
this
represents a lot of different cell types
and these cell types can also be in
different cellular states
we can have natural things that
heterogeneity so as i showed you with
the uh on the previous slide where about
20 of all of the proteins show this type
of thing is the heterogeneity that is
not due to cell cycle and we don't know
exactly what what these differences
arise from
and if we look again at the tumors we
also have the micro environment
so
to really understand what is going on in
these types of sample we need to look at
a lot of different cellular markets at
the same time
and
when it comes to clinical sample we also
want to maximize the information that we
can get from one sample as sometimes the
the sample materials can be very limited
so
we have been working with a few
multiplexed methods before but i really
now want to focus on
comets and and this instrument that
lunafor has developed and in our lab we
have been fortunate to beta test this
instrument now during summer and so i
will talk a bit more about how how this
experience has been
and if we start with the concept with
comets
and this is an instrument that allows
for a sequential immunopresence using
secondary fluorescently labeled
antibodies and that means then that we
do
you use off-the-shelf primary antibodies
that are detected with this secondary
antibodies thereof recently label
and this the instruments um provides
both staining and imaging in one
integrated instrument so it does it does
all of it in the same
and
as mentioned
the method for obtaining highly
multiplexed imaging is done as a
sequential if so that means that we
don't need to conjugate or do anything
to our primary antibodies and and for us
this is important
as we are integrated within the human
protein atlas project so we have
a lot of in-house generated antibodies
that we would like to apply for highly
multiplexed purposes as well
so the very brief step-by-step workflow
with comets is
following these six steps so we would
start with incubation of the primary
antibodies that can be two at the time
as long as they are from different
species
it would be followed by incubation with
the secondary antibodies then two were
two different species of the freshly
ones or the primary ones the the
instrument will image that and then the
antibody complex will be eluted with
illusion buffer and heat
and then this these steps are repeated
um
for additional number of time to build
up several cycles and
build up a highly multiplex panel
and all of the images are automatically
stacked in the end and allows you to
toggle on and off all of your different
markers so for us
as we are also
a national facility that are mainly
working with a service project for
others
it was important for us to evaluate the
robustness and the user friendliness of
the comet system
and also evaluate how the staining
quality and compatibility was across the
diverse
project site that we would have and that
means that it would work nicely across a
lot of different tissue types it should
also primarily or
preferentially work for cell cultures
and last but not least we wanted
this instrument to work well on our
in-house primary antibodies that we have
so
in order to evaluate all of this we we
wanted to apply a comet for building a
multiplex panel using our own antibodies
and when i say our own antibodies
it's rather atlas antibodies antibodies
and they have been collaborating with us
in this particular project
and atlas antibodies is the the provider
of all of the human protein atlas
antibodies that have been generated in
the beginning or from from these project
so
in this project that i will tell you
more about we focused on developing a
panel on for colorectal cancer
but and also to select a mix of markers
for evaluating the tissue quality the
staining quality across several tissue
types as outlined in above being the
second point here where we want to to be
have something that is compatible across
diverse projects that we might get to
the facility
so in collaboration with atlas
antibodies
we constructed a new tissue microarray
that you can see here to the right so it
consists of 19 human tissues 11 normal
tissue types and eight cancer
cores each of nine millimeters
and and what we like about comet is that
we can put all of this onto the very
same glass slide and then collect data
from all of this in the same run
so as you can see here this represents a
lot of different tissue types from
kidney a colon the small intestine lung
lymph node colorectal cancer test this
prostate and stomach
and
to also really leverage on on the
staining quality uh of these of this
tissue course we also selected a panel
of antibodies that we wanted to be part
of this panel
and the the main concept for us here was
to select
markers some markers that are expressed
in basically all tissue types to
evaluate the quality of the of the
staining
but then also to have some markers that
are more differentially expressed so
that we could have some for example set
b2 where we would have
a colorectal cancer being a positive
tissue for that particular marker by
being negative for most other
tissue types in our panel
and we have ck20 or ck7 that instead
would be negative for the colorectal
cancer by positive impressed so we try
to
we try to collect them or select
a nice set of markers that can allow us
to do proper evaluation of the data and
also gain as much information and
understanding
results as possible across across this
this tma
and just to show you one example so here
we have as i mentioned set b2 and this
is a marker that is known to be highly
expressed in colorectal cancer here you
can see the diminished chemistry image
panel on top
and the immunothreads inside the bottom
while when this marker being then
negative and the breast cancer and ck7
we have the opposite so we have it
negative in the breast cancer sorry in
the in the colorectal cancer why highly
positive in the breast cancer
and
so we knew which marker we wanted to
include to evaluate the comet in the
best way but of course it's also
extremely important to have antibodies
of good quality and that we can rely on
so that they are specific so that we
know that we get reliable data and
having the background in the human
protein atlas and having worked a lot
with antibody validation i want to spend
just a very short time on this
so
there are several approaches for how to
like validate antibodies for imaging
purposes
and the first one that would be
independent antibody strategies and that
simply mean that we try to select
antibodies where we have
antibodies targeting different epitopes
different parts of the the antigen that
are not overlapping and if they give
rise to the same standing pattern we can
be more certain that they are that they
are binding what what we believe that
they should bind to
and one can work with genetic strategies
so for example with strna where we would
have a scrambled well with the
proto-target protein not being knocked
down and then we would have an s rna
down regulating that particular protein
and what we want to see in this case if
the antibodies specific is that then the
signal intensity really decreases when
we have the s i rna knockdowns
there are the orthogonal strategies
so this would be comparing
for example rna-seq data
with imminent resistance and then this
should primarily or they should
preferentially correlate so if it would
have a higher rna expression
which we would also expect to have a
high standing pattern or or intensity
and and vice versa
and yet another approach for this would
be to express the target protein
with the gfp tag or other present tag
and then look for the overlap in
staining where we also then perform
immunophysics of that particular
cell type
and and all of these are methods that
that are implemented in the human
protein atlas and also atlas antibodies
so all of the antibodies that we
selected for this study have undergone
some of these really careful validation
strategies and they are all
then getting the label of being enhanced
and validated
so this is really important regardless
of a project that we will work with
and i will now move more toward how we
worked on building this multiplex panel
and and basically this is also something
that lunafore has has created a workflow
for and it
involves three main steps where that
would be the first one is the the
pre-treatment of the sample and that is
then the antigen retrieval at what
temperature which ph and so forth that
this is the sample is treated and here
we need to have something that is
working for all of the antibodies that
we include in the same multiplex panel
and the second step that would be to
test each and every antibodies to title
for the right concentration and also for
the incubation time that is needed
so
i think one of the unique aspects of
comet is that
it uses this chip technology that means
that the primary and secondary
antibodies are only incubated for
minutes uh which is usually done
overnight in our case so
uh we were interested also to to see how
well this performs uh as the incubation
time is so short in the comet essays
after that
it's also then about evaluating
the illusion time so the time needed for
each and every antibody to completely
remove the staining that we have and
this is of course important because then
we will move on to the next cycle where
we would add
the new pair of antibodies and we want
to make sure that we don't have any
remaining
staining from previous cycles there
so so these are the three main steps and
i will show you data uh also that that
shows the quality of the stainless that
we achieved and but also how we
systematically worked on that
so the first marker in our panel is cd3
a marker for t cells and this we
included because we knew we had many
many other course cancers being immune
cell rich
and but it's also a very common marker
for a variety of like other
highly multiplex systems and and their
pre and their panels that they offer
including also one that we have from
luna for
so here we can see the cd3 in colorectal
cancer and if we zoom in we can see that
we have a lot of these cells
in this in this particular case
we also included cd8 so
targeting modus cytotoxic t cells
and we can also see that this is working
very nicely this is i mean all of the
images that i show you now are
uh from our optimized runs where we
decided on like the right concentration
um staining incubation time and also the
exposure time of the upon imaging
here we have
our third marker cd68 a macrophage
marker
and in this case we see that we have
some macrophages infiltrating this
tissue core
i should say that all of these
antibodies that we work with we also
have let's say
the
um
ground truth data from conventional
immunist to chemistry images so we know
we know that it's the impacts that we
get here
is in concordance to what we see
in the in the convention eliminates the
chemistry using these same antibodies
here is clear 67
a high degree of proliferating cells
and then we have pipe2 polyadp rivals
polymerase one so this is one of the
markers that are expressed in all of the
tissues but we chose now also to
evaluate it for for quality in the in
the color rectal
so you can see it's expressed in most
cells of the glands and also the stroma
then we move to the histone the
acetylase and here we have staining of
the nucleoplasm of cells as we expect to
have
also
one of these markers that should be
expressed in all of the tissues that we
would have in our tma
and moving on here is yet another marker
so this is the fast cell surface death
receptor
and
yet another marker that we express that
we expect to be expressed in in most
tissue types and also in this one so it
stains very nicely the
the cell membrane
then we go to the the cytokeratin seven
and if you remember so this is the one
that we expect to be negative in correct
cancer and for this one also we don't
see at all
at all in this core but if we move to
this next slide here we can see that
so being
colorectal cancer being a negative
tissue type for this but they for the to
the right here we see that we have a
very strong expression of the same mark
in breast cancer as we expected as well
so by this we can still say that
the titration of this particular marker
is is working well and that we are happy
with these results
then move on to
set b2 and and this is one of the most
biologically interesting markers that we
have in our panel and so this is a
prognostic marker or i would say like a
it's a marker for
differentiating between uh a lot of
different cancer types uh so
it's it's
so it's um it's a very sensitive and
specific marker for colorectal cancer
and especially in combination with some
of the different cytokeratins that we
also have in the panel and then it's
also a promising diagnostic biomarker
for both like primary colorectal cancer
but also secondary metastasis derived
from colorectal cancer
and as you can see here it's it's
positively stained for all of this core
and we can also zoom in on this here
so uh if we move to the last part of how
to build up the panel we need to look at
the illusion
time and also the epitope stability for
all of the markers so that we know where
in the panel we can have all of these
markers
so what you see here is part one in one
of the course and also counter-sting
with opi you can hardly see it here but
this is after
the first illusion cycle where we test
this
or the staining itself and what we want
to see then after the illusion is that
this staining completely uh bleaches
away from from the illusion step
so this looks pretty good to us whether
one can wish for slightly even higher
removal on this particular stating
and and one thing a lesson that we
learned when we were working with this
is also that
so this is this is the staining after
the first illusion realm
and usually one expect that the staining
and the epitope stability would decrease
across several illusion cycles but what
we see for this particular marker is
that the staining actually increases
after several rounds of evolution
probably because this epitope becomes
more
accessible
so so this is like this is one of the
market that we put towards the very end
of our protocol because we could see
that this epitope could clearly
withstand all of these additional runs
of illusion and we can then
um
adjust for this by decreasing the
concentration of the antibody and also
like decreasing the exposure time of
this marker
so so this was also done for all of the
markers and and then we worked on
putting all of these together and
here you can see the table for all of
the antibodies that we evaluated so
we have them you can see here what cycle
we put them in and the working dilution
the corresponding working concentration
and the exposure time and
and
it doesn't really make sense to show
everything in one one slide but this is
the one
image that we put together showing six
of these different markers so you can
see that here to the to the right and if
we zoom in on this we can see that it's
it's really providing like a nice
nice staining with all of these
different cell types representing
proliferating cells the macrophages
and t cells and the cytotoxic t cells
and then the part one
and i also wanted to say that we for us
we also work a lot with cell culture so
we also wanted to test the comet's
instrument on cell cultures to see if if
these cells actually stayed attached
across all of these different uh
cycles of repeated staining and illusion
and and
and also if if some of our in-house
antibodies were working nicely also on
cells
and what you see here is staining of a
nucleoplasmic protein in u2 os cells
and this is after
10 cycles so that would correspond to a
trend duplex and we can see that we
still have like all of the cells here
and we also get the very nice staining
of the nucleoplasm in this case
so that was working very nicely and here
is just also two other example using two
other standard antibodies commercial
ones this time and staining
caloriticulin so the er here in yellow
and this is also alpha tubulin for the
microtubules
so this is also something that we didn't
optimize but we will continue and work
more on that
and and because we have a lot of a lot
of interesting projects uh where we want
to where we want to use comet also for
sales
so
i want to say that we also after beta
tested this instrument we secured
funding so we will get our own comet
instrument to the spatial proteomics
facility uh in december and that means
that we plan to start offering comet
projects as a service from from next
year in 2022
the final slide and to put what we do in
a context what what i have been talking
about now is the special proteomics
facility
here at scilab lab but we are also part
of a platform that provides different
types of special omics services so this
is the spatial and seeing a cell biology
platform at scilab lab
so if you look at the bottom here the
idea is that we get samples from the
user and then we can use different
technologies so spatial transcriptomics
or nct sequencing
special mass spectrometry for example to
combine different layers of omics
across the tissue sections and then get
the data back to the user
so if you're also interesting
interested in any of that and you can
you can also contact me but but also of
course for that for the work that i have
presented here
in this webinar
so
i want to thank the funders and our
collaborators and for this particular
project so everyone in my team that has
been involved in this unlike carolina
inline eleanor and a big thanks of
course first of all to luna for for
giving us the opportunity to beat that
has this instrument and for atlas
antibodies who has done this fantastic
work with creating this
tissue microwave that we worked with
and also helping us select a good good
antibodies for this and especially
thanks to carolyn marks who has done an
incredible job in this project
uh emma lundberg's lab and the human
protein atlas for what we have done on
the self culture work
and then all of you for listening and
and thanks also again for to luna for
who gave me the opportunity to to
present this work
thank you
thank you charlotte for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
so let's get started
could you summarize the key reasons why
you are integrating the comet platform
into your lab
yes so i think that there are many
reasons
so as i mentioned we have some
experience with working with other multi
highly multiplexed methods
and those rely on the conjugation of
antibodies and and that means that we
have been it has not been so
straightforward for us to use all of the
primary of shelf antibodies that we have
from the human protein atlas so
i think for us what comet offers is then
a way for us to use this primary of the
shelf antibodies that also have been
used within the human protein nest so we
know that you know we know which ones
that are working well and in what type
of tissue
so that means that it would be like more
straightforward for us to to start
applying them for multiplex imaging
thank you
next question
for your research and service lab
activities what is the typical plex
level you are expecting
so i i think that
depends a bit on on the user that will
come to us so
um
some are very interested in doing more
of discovery proteomics where you want
to look at very many proteins uh
with the other platform that we work
with so far a codex i mean they're
they're usually we stay in between
around 20 markers
and but i can see that this level of
place could be both even higher but it
could also be lower i think that when we
work with more clinical samples and
people with a you know a clinical
background
only doing let's say 10 to 12 plex will
give a lot of useful information
to them and in their samples
okay
next question for what you have
experienced what are the advantages of
being able to use off-the-shelf primary
antibodies
yes so so i think that i mean what is
nice is that if
for us and also many that are contacting
us they already have antibodies that
they are working with
but they do that at the singleplex or
maybe twoplex
and and for them it's often
comforting if they could use the same
antibodies as they are used to and again
when it comes to clinical samples
they might be particular antibodies that
they really need to stick to
so i think that you know that they can
use those directly without the need for
conjugation
uh offers let's say a lower threshold to
get started
and and test their projects
and build on that
thank you
next question
given the number of sequential staining
cycles have you observed any epitopes
degradation or deterioration in tissue
morphology
so
uh in in this when we have now the
comets in our lab which was still during
a rather limited time period and our
experience is mostly then done with this
tissue microwave and and that represents
a variety of tissue types
however we have mostly looked into the
colorectal cancer core the data that i
showed you here
and but i say it really really depends
on
the sample type so the tissue type the
quality of the original tissue type in
general
and
the protein target and and those
particular epitopes so i think that it's
just
i cannot give any answer of you know
which exact markers are working or not
and what we have seen is that the
overall
in this tissue microarray that we work
with a lot and also for the cells we can
see that the morphology seems to be very
well retained after the 10 cycles that
we have worked with so that would
correspond to a 20 plex
and we haven't run more than 10 cycles
but whatever
10
we are we're still confident and we're
happy with how the morphology look
across these uh different tissue types
that we have in the pattern in the in
the tma
thank you
next question maybe i can also maybe i
can just also add one thing so
also for the cells uh this was something
the cell culture this was something that
we that we really like tested i i don't
think that luna 4 had done so much on
cells but the focus is really on tissues
and i would expect that the
cell cultures are a bit more let's say
vulnerable to these heating
illusion cycles but but also those
individual cells looked really nice from
you know the markers that we evaluated
even though there weren't
too many subsets of organelles that we
but that we looked at but but still like
all of our standard markers the tubulin
for example is a very good marker in
general for the quality and the
morphology of the cells then that one
looked beautiful after the 10 cycles
okay
next question
is there tissue degradation on every
cycle what about repeatability
um
yes so
again i think that
i think that there might be
proteins i mean specific proteins that
do get
partially degraded perhaps after a lot
of number of repeated cycles
and but we haven't we haven't looked or
found a particular proteins
there uh
so so again i i think that we just that
we can mostly just refer to the overall
morphology of what we've seen
um
what we've seen also so normally we work
with ph 6 when we do the antigen
retrieval
upstream of the staining
and and that is
i mean that is a bit of a milder
treatment
and i know that that is also what many
clinicians are using because it
preserves the morphology a little bit
better even though it tends to give
slightly weaker signals just because the
tissue is not fast let's say degraded
and all of the epitopes are not as open
so so i think that it's a lot about the
upstream processing of the sample and to
optimize for the particular tissue and
sulfur type that one is
that one is uh working with and we did
not spend
too much time
on that sort of those conditions but
rather implementing the austrian
protocol that we normally work with
in our lab also outside of comet
thank you
next question
is there a possibility to reuse the same
tissue slide for other spatial omics
techniques and co-register them
this is nothing that we have tried
it's something that we certainly will
try
and
i think that it would be possible
i mean also again depending on what
other omics type that one would look at
if on what you combine it with fish for
example or any type of rna analysis i
might do that before the iaf staining
with comet to make sure that the rna is
intact
and
and i mean as far as image core
registration i know that there are
many people that are doing that so i
think it would be possible
what i can say is that after the comment
that we have done and we have saved
saved the the sections and then we have
looked at it after a while again and
it's just that it still looks okay but
but we haven't really tried
yet
okay thank you
next question
another detection question the abstract
mentioned use of dna barcoded antibodies
did that method stand up to the
standards in your lab and antibody
performance
um so so the question was about
how this compared to the dna barcoded
antibodies or
um
i think so
so i think that i think that's what we
can see is that we we
the the quality of the stainings that we
get with comet
uh
i mean we're very happy with them and
we're also very happy with the the
quality that we have for other platforms
using dna barcoded antibodies so the
codex platform that we also have in our
lab
and
so so i think that
maybe like the only difference is that
with the dna barcoded ones there is no
amplification step
so the signals might be a bit weaker um
and
depending on the marker the targets of
interest i mean this
this might makes it trickier
but we also have in that setup the
possibility to really
i mean optimize the antibody
dilution and also the exposure time for
that particular so
we haven't either with the dna barcode
once we haven't experienced markers that
we could not use
so it's just that it requires
conjugation before we can before we can
run those two samples but more for the
device and how the images and and the
data look like
i think they're very comparable
okay thank you
looks like we have time for one more
question
fantastic technology and great talk my
question is how do you deal with tissue
autofluorescence is this an issue
between the cycles
so this is a very good and an
interesting relevant question i would
say so
again
the water fluorescence i mean it becomes
can be more or less tricky depending on
the tissue type um we have like prior to
the comet work uh with together with
emma lumbre's lab implemented some like
protocols for reducing auto fluorescence
and and it's it's quite it's say easy in
one way so we we illuminate the the
sample with an led lamp uh for
i think it's around a two two times one
hour
and also treated with hydrogen peroxide
for a while and we have seen that that
very efficiently reduces the autoforest
sense then i know that the comet system
also allows you to work with different
different methods or different buffers i
should say to
to you know continuously
try to remove and block other
fluorescents across the cycles we do see
that we get some more other freshness
building up
over the cycles
um
so so i think this also makes it
important that all of the empty bodies
that one include in the panel give a
strong let's say signal to noise ratio
and then i think that the water freshens
background
uh there are many ways for how that can
be removed afterwards as long as your
signal to noise from the antibodies is
strong enough in relation to your
background from the autophores
well thank you
and thank you again charlotte for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor lunafore for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye